hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from round three
of the United States 2018 championship
here we have a game between Jeffrey
Zhang and Fabiano Caruana
now you already seen a couple of videos
about young on my channel we had that
one against I want early and I believe
and the one against Magnus Carlsen and
here he has the white pieces against the
World Chess Championship challenger
Fabiana Caruana
Jeffrey's Young is the United States
third youngest Grandmaster after a one
ruling and Samuel 7 in 2016 he won the
World Junior Chess Championship title
and also in 2016 he was the wild card in
the United States Championship where he
won an excellent sixth place out of 12
contenders that's that's amazing for a
16 year old and today well he is 18
years old and only a month before the
United States Championship
he won't a very strong st. Louis Spring
Classic with a rating performance of I
believe it's twenty eight hundred and
nineteen so pretty unbelievable results
and here a true test of skill for him he
faces Fabiano Caruana and finally a game
where we don't see the French whenever
but rather a nice benoni so let's see
the game d4 by Jeffrey and Knight to f6
Knight to f3 d6 so a bit of a
transposition into the benoni
c4 c5 and now we do have d5 d6 Knight to
c3 he captures C captures and now g6 so
the full benoni
modern variation and here Geoffrey goes
for Bishop to f4 if you remember from my
Talbot Phoenix series in Game two of
their match Botvinnik went for Bishop to
g5 and then later tall after he
developed played h6 g5 kicked the bishop
all the way to g3 and then played
Knights to h5 and grabbed that Bishop
and opened Botvinnik
what makes h-file and after a long
series struggle that game ended in a
draw
Geoffrey it seems does not approve of
both Phoenix idea he goes Bishop to f4
Bishop to g7 now comes a three we have
castles h3
and Queen to e7 nice to be - preparing
to transfer tonight perhaps the c4 if if
if allowed them the d6 pawn could become
seriously under attack so far be
immediately goes for the Bishop Knight
to h5 Bishop - H - now you can see how
very useful the h3 move was not only
stopping any Bishop to g4 ideas but also
making room for the bishop on h2 and now
comes f5 so now nice the c4 will be will
be met by simply removing the Queen we
have Bishop to e2 F for now and I
already a move and move 12 we have a
very interesting position what do you do
here well the problem with this obvious
Bishop captures on h5 I mean why
wouldn't you do it is that Fabiano can
simply play F captures on e3 and now
your knight is under attack your Bishop
is under attack and white and black will
definitely win back his piece but what
do you do here is black of course if you
capture then pawn captures here and then
your Bishop will still be under attack
and if you play F characters here then
you get a Bishop captures and c3 pawn
captures and now G captures on h5 and
you're not gonna Castle kingside as the
rook is controlling the F file you
definitely don't want to go Queen side
the Queen side is all shattered you can
see this III point is very weak the
Queen is attacking it it's a very
dangerous position for white and in in a
practical game white does not want to
play this so after f4 we have castles by
Geoffrey and Phi because F captures on
d3
we have 90 to e4 so upon sacrifice we
have he captures on f2 and now King to
h1 Bishop captures on c3 and now again
you don't have time for an in-between
move wood Bishop captures here because
the knight on e4 is hanging so you do
have to capture this bishop with the
knight Knight captures and now Knight to
g7 finally getting getting that night
away from h5 not allowing the bishop to
capture it and here there's this very
annoying f2 pawn of fab' pushed all the
way to f2 and you have to get rid of it
but getting rid of it will give a 4 with
some very poor
temples activate his pieces and get back
into the game
so Bishop to f3 now the rook will be
able to capture the pawn 937 rook
captures on f2 and Knight to e5 so now
the knight occupies an excellent central
square if white wants to eliminate it
you will have to give up his strong dark
square Bishop rook to e2 now pinning
this Knight also with a double attack on
it and now Knight to f5 and now if white
plays a slow move this night is coming
to d4 and then White's position will be
very difficult to play so Geoffrey
doesn't allow Dixie plays Bishop
captures on e5 we have D captures on d5
and d6 he decides to sacrifice a pawn
here to activate his pieces as much as
he can
so Knight captures nb6 you can't go
Queen captures on d6 because then simply
Queen captures Knight captures and white
wins back the pawn on e5 would the rook
so this was the idea
Knight captures and e6 we have Queen to
d5 this comes with check knight to f7
now now the knight from F seven blocks
check and also there's a double defense
of d5 points so Fabi is Fabi still keeps
his pawn Knight to e4 now with a double
attack on the c5 form and there's no way
to really defend the c5 phone so
Geoffrey will win back the C pawn the
problem is what do you play here is
black well if you play something like
Bishop to e6 as you see you can't defend
the c5 pawn maybe we just want to give
it away the problem is after Queen
captures Queen captures and Knight
captures now your b7 point is also gonna
fall and there's no real way to defend
it
the knight and the bishop are attacking
it if you play b6 of course you lose the
rook here so after Knight to e4 Fabi
simply played rook to b8
getting the rock out of this nasty 8
square and this this will allow him to
put b6 when the Queen's come off the
board Queen captures on c5 Queen
captures Knight captures and now the
simple b6 which is now possible as the
rook is no longer an 8 9 3 4 and Bishop
to f5 so after all is said and done Fabi
is up a piece and a fob is up a pawn and
it's a very important and
strong past epon nice to see three rugby
to be eight and we have a for now
Geoffrey is hoping for a five to mess up
this this very nice pawns on the win
side about five he pushes a five himself
we have Bishop to d5 now pinning this
night so now rook captures an e5 is a
threat so rook FTE eight defending the
pawn now comes Bishop captures King
characters and now rope to f1 with the
threat of g4 to win the bishop on f5
acting to e6 getting the King out of the
way and now rook to e1 threatening leap
on and here Fabi repeats came to f6 we
have rook to f1 and King back to e6 rock
after he won and now if Bobby would
continue King to have six we would have
a draw by threefold repetition but Bobby
doesn't want it doesn't want this so he
plays King to d6 rook to e3 and we have
King to c6 and now Knight the b5 kink
rook to e7
now comes g4 and Bishop to d3 Bishop to
d3 what's the idea of not allowing this
rook to come to c3 also oops sorry
also would ideas that later this Bishop
is coming to c4 and b3 to attack da for
pawn as DF four points on a light square
Fabi has a light square bishop this is
excellent for Fabi Knight to c3
we have Bishop to c4 now comes work to
c1 and King back to b7 does Bobby
doesn't want his King to occupy the same
the same file as the rook rook to e4
attacks the bishop now comes Luke to d4
he offers the exchange of rooks King g1
and now Bishop to b3 now with a double
attack on the a four points so
definitely now this would be very
dangerous King to f2 first rope to d2
check Rock blocks as now the B to pawn
was attacked
rook to f7 check King three three and
now Rock back to d4
now again attacking the a four point
nice to b5 attacking the rook rook who
goes all the way back you have to be
very careful of course you don't want to
play rook captures here and then simply
nice nice
d6 check would window rock on f7 so
first you have to go back now we have an
ID back the c3 and now rook to f4 and
now there is a no way to defend the a
four point anymore Rock the d2 we have
roped the d4 first rock back to f2 and
now finally Bishop captures an a4 so now
fabi's up two points and this is now
this is now pretty much unplayable Rock
to have six still hoping for some ideas
maybe Knight captures an a4 would Rock
the c6 maybe to create some perpetual
ideas but simply push up to c6 and after
Bishop to c6 Jeff Roussillon resigned
the game so a second victory in a row
for for Fabiano Caruana which joins the
lead in the United States Championship
and I'm still gonna wear a wait a bit
with the results and with the standings
maybe after maybe after maybe after the
today's round I will start showing them
here Jeffrey's young resigned because
now there's really nothing to do you're
down two points you could try something
like rook captures King captures 92
check to win back the rook but I mean
rookie 7 the rock is coming there's
there's really no counter play here so
it would on it would only be torture
after Bishop to c6 he resigned so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and there is no one after this is round
three there is no one with who is 3 out
of 3 so unfortunately no one will be
winning the fish reward for winning the
tournament with a perfect score but such
a thing in today's just is is really
unthinkable me but maybe next year who
knows so I would like to thank Nikola
Dobrev John Roberts and Emery Gian for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting video hopefully
thank you